ينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام
الياس ابدا معك اولا عن قاله قائد سريه في
الكتيبه 51 في لواء
جولاني في اي سياق تمت عمليه الاقاله
ولماذا
الان هي الاقاله جاءت من قائد الكتيبه
لقائد هذا السريه لانه خالف تعليماته
العسكريه وبعدم الدخول الى بعض المنازل
الفلسطينيه في حي الشجاعيه عندما كانت
العمليات العسكريه على اشدها في هذا الحي
الذي شهد معارك ضاريه في الاسابيع
الثلاثه الماضيه الجنود الاسرائيليون
الذين كانوا ضمن مجموعه من القوات
الاسرائيليه في مدرعات من نوع نمير كانوا
يخشون التعرض الى ضربات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بصواريخها مضاده للدروع ف طلب
منهم قائد السريه ان يترجل من ناقلات
الجند ويتوجه نحو منازل فلسطينيه في حي
الشجاعيه خلافا
لتعليمات قائد الكتيبه رقم 51 وهي احدى
الكتائب التابعه للواء جولاني حيث ان قائد
الكتيبه انذرهم بان هذه المنازل قد تكون
مفخخه وقد يتم تفعيل متفجرات ضد الجنود
الاسرائيليين لكن قائد السيريه خالف هذه
التعليمات و طلب من جنوده ان يدخلوا الى
بعض المنازل في حي الشجاعيه في هذا الحادث
تحديدا جمال لم تقع اصابات في صفوف الجنود
الاسرائيليين لكن الامر استدعى اقاله
مباشره وفوريه من جانب قائد الكتيبه لقائد
السريه الذي خالف تعليماته في هذا السياق
على اعتبار ان هنالك تحذيرات شديده من
جانب القوات الاسرائيليه وتحديدا القيادات
العليا من ضروره توخي الحيطه والحظر من
جانب القوات الاسرائ يه في توغلات في داخل
الاحياء ال الفلسطينيه ليس فقط بسبب ما قد
يواجهونه من اخطار الانفاق الهجوميه او
فتوحات الانفاق التي يخرج منها المقاتلون
الفلسطينيون ويسدد الضربات لهم انما ايضا
من مخاوف ان تكون هنالك مبان ومعاقل ربما
تابعه لحركه حماس عندما يدخلونها تكون
مفخخه وقد جرى ذلك على الاقل مره واحده في
حي الشجاعيه عندما ادى ذلك الى مقتل تسعه
جنود اسرائيليين وكانوا قد وقعوا في فخ
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي فخخ احد المنازل
في في الحي مما اسفر عن سقوط اربعه جنود
قتلى وعندما كانت مجموعه اخرى تحاول
التقدم لمساعدتهم تم تفعيل عبوه متفجره
ثانيه فجاءت المجموعه الثالثه وحاولت
انقاذ المجموعتين السابقتين وتعرضت هي
ايضا لتفجير ث لكان لذلك كانت جمال
التعليمات صارمه للغايه في ضروره توخي ما
يصدر من اوامره من القيادات العليا حول
عدم الدخول الى المنازل التي قد تكون
مفخخه وبالتالي قائد السريه هذا خالف هذه
التعليمات وعوقب
بالاقالته وبالتالي جرى تعيين قائد جديد
لهذه السريه في مكانه الياس كرام مراس
الجزيره في تلبيب شكرا لك وامامي خبر عاجل
من الكتائب كتائب القسام